Sam Sam excuse me to do what's up
powering let's meet you
so can you tell us a little bit about
what you're gonna be doing the current
record right now is four minutes and 48
seconds fully engulfed on fire our moms
are in town for the weekend and we were
like trying to figure out stuff to do
and like art museums for how are you
gonna pass the time when you're on fire
cuz I mean five to eight minutes
you know that's I'm not allowed to have
an oxygen source so really what I'm
doing is I'm holding my breath and then
is my face comes through the flames I
take small breaths if you were to inhale
fire it's a pretty big deal spray him
with more fuel in from head to toe to
continue the flame for burning and if it
starts to die down if I have to I'll
literally chase behind him spraying him
down with the fuel like a super soaker
pull like gasoline early now yeah we
have a thing actually we tested with
super soakers fuel do you think you'd be
going to anything like this no I was not
planning on any human being
walking and fire being burned in fires
really wide area everybody's gonna
happen if it's something were to happen
tonight call 9-1-1 and i'll be carted
away it's no big deal
yeah daddy
yeah
forty-five
[Applause]
5:23 that's what it say okay cool thank
you thanks buddy
you